[Musique]
tellement ri qu'elle a fait un malaise
donc là on a un problème vous savez
c'est une obligation légale en fait
d'aller à la police quand tu n'auras
cadavre sur les bras
on n'aurait jamais dû faire ça on a voté
non pas s'il n'y a pas une seule
personne ici qu'un plan donc bas aussi
on n'a qu'à l'enterrer dans la forêt
communale
personne ne trouvera l'homme mais on
peut pas des cons y creuse on t'emmerde
ils vont trouver non plus appartient la
ville donc sinon la jeu dans la vilaine
et puis ça lui non parce que
écologiquement déjà c'est pas possible
et ensuite le bien commun merci puis ça
va nous faire une affaire qu'à gori
numéro de ses moyens ou bien sûr que si
on pouvait les gens en antarctique ça
règlerait le problème c'est loin c'est
froid etc appartient personnes alors à
qui appartient en partie parce que même
si vous n'êtes pas juriste le droit
international pour la base on s'est un
peu comment ça se passe au sens du droit
un état c'est trois éléments un
territoire même si dans de nombreux pays
les frontières sont parfois contestées
est l'objet de conflits une population
sur ce territoire qui va être soumis aux
règles de droit de cet état et un
pouvoir institutionnalisée avec un
gouvernement qui va avoir certaines
prérogatives
ça inclut les cas également où le
pouvoir n'est pas légitime où le
gouvernement n'est pas démocratique où
il ya des luttes internes etc
mais pour l'antarctique vous conviendrez
que c'est un petit peu plus compliqué
car l'antarctique n'est pas un état mais
un continent tout entier
mais pour le grand public l'antarctique
à part savoir le situer et savoir qu'il
ait fait globalement très froid on n'en
sait pas grand chose
l'antarctique et donc le continent le
plus méridional de la terre avec une
superficie de 14 millions de kilomètres
carrés oui moi non plus je mens pas du
tout compte de ce que ça fait donc dites
vous que l'antarctique est plus grand
que l'europe et l'océanie 14 millions de
kilomètres carrés oui mais ça c'est en
été car en hiver ça double l'eau va
geler et on dépasse les 30 millions de
kilomètres carrés en moyenne
l'antarctique à des températures pouvant
aller jusqu'à moins 80 degrés et c'est
le dernier continent à avoir été exploré
c'est marrant parce que du point de vue
géologique c'est hyper intéressant
d'antarctique en fait sur la partie est
tu as tu trouves des rushes contre trois
milliards d'années quand tu sais que la
terre entière à 4,5 milliards d'années
c'est vraiment des roches qui date de sa
prime jeunesse
ah oui c'est vrai c'est ultra rare en
fait c'est un peu genre si tu marchais
et tu tombais sur ses dents de lait quoi
la condition que tu marches en
antarctique et du coup c'est un peu
moins mais du coup en faite le il ya
sans doute plein de trésors qu'on n'a
pas encore découvert en antarctique
parce que 98 % de sa surface est
recouverte de glace une couche qui fait
genre deux kilomètres d'épaisseur enfin
c'est énorme
il ya plus de 170 millions d'années en
fait ça faisait partie du super
continent gondwana et du coup c'était
sous un climat tropical le gondwana
c'était un peu le lap répond j'ai tu
vois et du coup là tu pouvais y avoir
des jungles tropicales feinte imagine
avec des fougères avec les ancêtres des
combos fin c'était la folie quoi et puis
peu à peu il s'est détaché 2 de
l'australie et après on dernier moment
de l'amérique du sud
et puis à ce moment là une fois qu'il
était tout seul il ya un courant qui
s'est mis en place tout autour qui
s'appelle le courant circumpolaire
antarctique c'est le plus puissant que
qu'on connaisse sur terre et ça c'est
vraiment un moteur de la du climat à
l'échelle globale parce que d'une part
sans pêche les eaux chaudes de
redescendre et toucher les côtes
antarctique donc sa garde le climat
enfin le way le climat très froid en
antarctique même et puis en plus ça
permet de remonter les eaux froides qui
sont en profondeur sous l'océan et et
c'est en fait c'est ça qui fait le
moteur de ce qu'on appelle la
circulation thermohaline c'est le tapis
roulant des océans ou jean stu trace une
molécule d'eau à un endroit donné tu
peux la laisser nager et elle fera le
tour de tous les océans elle reviendra
au même endroit dans milan ou dans mes
cinq sens à peu près c'est ce qui est
aujourd'hui du coup on ne sait pas
forcément mais c'est un climat qui est
extrêmement froid ou sanxay et il est
sec aussi parce que c'est il pleut
quasiment pas là bas c'est en fait le
plus grand désert du monde l'antarctique
et du coup tu as une faune et une flore
très particulières qui sont développés
là bas tu auras pas d'arbres mais tu
auras des herbes des algues du week-end
des trucs comme ça et puis en animaux
t'auras pas des manchots des phoques
et puis le cadavre de d'explorateurs un
peu trop hardie et voilà donc tout ça
pour dire qui a pas de population
indigène en antarctique on en n'a pas
trouvé en tout cas ok c'est pas trop
longtemps à l'antenne par contre depuis
quand c'est ton que l'antarctique existe
parce que même si c'est de l'histoire on
peut aisément deviner que c'est à partir
de ce moment là que remontent les
questionnements concernant à qui cela
appartenait et éventuellement le début
des premières sources de droit sur le
sujet alors on a quelques traces des
premières spéculations sur l'existence
de l'antarctique qui remonte à
l'antiquité avec la dénomination terra
australis autrement dit terres australes
plus tard on voit cette dénomination
reporter sur diverses cartes comme sur
celle d'abraham ortelius en quinze cent
soixante dix où cette carte 10 771 on
voit que les contours restent très
vagues et globalement de cette terre
australe on ne sait pas grand chose ce
ne sera qu en 1819 qu'on peut
formellement attestée qu'on connaissait
l'antarctique
c'est le navigateur britannique william
smith qui fera cette observation
l'antarctique suscite alors bien plus
d'intérêt subissant alors une intense
chasse au phoque ce qui mènera à une
quasi extinction de certaines espèces et
vous savez qu'elle existe quatre espèces
de manchots non on va faire pas mal
d'histoire et de géopolitique et même un
petit peu de géographie car tous ces
éléments sont indispensables pour
comprendre les enjeux de l'antarctique
puis le droit ça me saoule cherchent un
plan de reconversion aussi lire un texte
juridique que ce soit une loi ou un
traité international n'a pas beaucoup de
substance si on s'intéresse pas au
contexte
sans ça on ne s'intéresseraient qu'est
la loi brut si j'ose dire et on perdra
des informations très précieuses
d'ailleurs la loi ne veut pas toujours
tous précisé et anticiper tous les cas
de figure c'est donc le juge notamment
qui va finir par trancher avec son
pouvoir d'interprétation de la loi est
une loi ça ne s'interprète pas avec
notre petit avis sur la question
on va s'intéresser à quel était
l'objectif poursuivi pour ceux qui l'ont
écrite et donc on va devoir comprendre
le contexte de son écriture
ce sont ces éléments qui vont nous
permettre de répondre aux interrogations
dont la réponse n'est pas écrite noir
sur blanc et c'est un exercice
passionnant
en 1959 12 pays signe le premier traité
international au sujet de l'antarctique
on y reviendra un petit peu plus tard
car je suis obligé de faire un état des
lieux avant de vous parler du traité
plus en profondeur
parce qu'avant 1959 est-ce que
l'antarctique était une zone nombre
revendiqué est neutre est ce qu'on
voulait juste le marquer dans le marbre
du traité pour éviter toute dérive
évidemment que non certains états avait
bien des revendications sur le sujet et
plus exactement 7
les cinq premiers sont le royaume-uni la
france l'australie la nouvelle-zélande
et la norvège qui argumente une
légitimité de possession avec les
découvertes réalisées aux 19e siècle ils
ne sont donc accorder des droits
historiques sur les bandes de terre de
l'antarctique
répartis en triangle allant de la côte
jusqu'au pôle en gros premier arrivé
premier servi
en 1940 deux autres pays vont se
rajouter aux cinq premiers l'argentine
et le chili
clamant leur droit notamment au prétexte
d'une continuité géographique on est en
bas donc c'est à nous évidemment ça a
créé un conflit puisque les zones
revendiquées par l'argentine et le chili
appartenait déjà au royaume uni donc
vous voyez les forces sous les vidéos
youtube ont toujours existé finalement
entre 1957 et 1958 se tient l'année
géophysique internationale qui a pour
but de mener des recherches en
antarctique beaucoup de bases
scientifiques se sont installés là-bas
pour réaliser des recherches et il
apparaissait absolument nécessaire de
pouvoir les encadrer pour éviter qu'on y
fasse tout et n'importe quoi surtout
lorsque l'année géophysique
internationale pour enfants l'urss veut
potentiellement maintenir ses bases sur
le territoire et ça effraie un peu les
etats-unis qui veulent évidemment ne pas
rester sur la touche
attendez 1959 on web ouais la guerre
froide ça ça change tout donc forcément
l'antarctique va devenir lui même un
enjeu parce qu'il est effectivement faux
de penser que l'antarctique
n'intéressait personne à l'époque et ce
pour deux raisons
déjà c'est un lieu stratégique à 1000 km
du cap horn donc à l'extrémité de
l'amérique du sud
si le canal de panama était fermée et
que l'antarctique de d une zone de
conflit
les plus communiquer entre océan
pacifique et océan atlantique mais aussi
qu'avant partie contient énormément de
ressources minières a notamment du
charbon et du pétrole
ce genre de truc qui attire pas du tout
les combatifs vous voyez on voit donc on
a déjà quelques conflits entre
l'argentine et le chili vis-à-vis du
royaume-uni est évidemment entre l'urss
et les états unis
il est donc important de négocier dès
maintenant pour couper court à une
éventuelle est ce qu est la détention
c'est la guerre froide on le rappelle
donc c'est chaud les etats-unis invitent
à la table des négociations les pays qui
ont participé aux recherches
scientifiques sur le continent donc la
grande bretagne la france l'australie la
nouvelle-zélande et la norvège qui ont
déjà leur petite part de camembert
l'argentine et le chili qui ont des
revendications l'urss et l'afrique du
sud la belgique et le japon
qu'est ce qu'il fonde en fait ces douze
pays vont se réunir à washington et au
terme des négociations parviendront à
signer en 1959 le très sobrement
intitulé traité sur l'antarctique et qui
va donc réglementer les relations entre
les états signataires
par ailleurs ce traité n'est pas très
long seulement sept pages regroupant
treize articles comme je vous le disais
cette signature se fait un an après
l'année géophysique internationale où
beaucoup de scientifiques se sont
penchés son sujet il faut donc préserver
la zone et inscrire dans les textes
notamment pour continuer à mener des
recherches scientifiques dans de bonnes
conditions
l'objectif poursuivi par le traité est
donc inscrit noir sur blanc dès son
introduction sous la formule qu'il est
de l'intérêt de l'humanité toute entière
que l'antarctique soit à jamais réservé
aux seules activités pacifiques et ne
deviennent ni le théâtre ni l'enjeu de
différends internationaux
l'article premier donne tout de suite le
ton article
un petit 1 seules les activités
pacifiques sont autorisés dans
l'antarctique sont interdites entre
autres toutes mesures de caractère
militaire tels que l'établissement de
bases la construction de fortifications
les manoeuvres ainsi que les essais
d'armes de toutes sortes petit 2 le
présent traité ne s'oppose pas à
l'emploi de personnel ou de matériel
militaire pour la recherche scientifique
ou pour toutes autres fins pacifiques
donc on autorise seulement les activités
pacifiques en antarctique
c'est donc une façon de couper l'herbe
sous le pied à d'éventuelles mises en
place de bases militaires ou pire la
réalisation d'essais nucléaires
ces morts sur une activité pacifique en
tout cas est vieille comme le monde
déclenche pas une guerre nucléaire
ça c'est eux qui le dit même s'ils ont
l'air quand même un peu venir là pour
quatre manches on est un peu poudreuse
mais vous vous doutez bien que les
discussions restent quelque peu
intéressé et il faut pas déconner on va
pas renoncer à certains de nos acquis
aucun des cinq états qui se sont
découpées l'antarctique ne va renoncer à
sa souveraineté sur les terres qu'ils
convoitent on l'a marqué noir sur blanc
à l'article 4 du traité
donc sur ce point précis on glisse de
façon à peine dissimulé le sujet sous le
tapis c'est un peu love
on verra plus tard mais en mieux dicko
toutefois le gros point de réussite de
ce traité c'est que l'objectif de
préservation de la zone à des fins de
recherche scientifique est atteint le
traité mais même en place une
coopération entre les états pour qu'ils
échangent les renseignements qu'ils ont
recueillies dans le but je cite
d'assurer au maximum l'économie des
moyens et le rendement des opérations
l'objectif est aussi de préserver la
faune et la flore et on prévoit même
dans le traité la désignation
d'observateurs pour vérifier que toutes
ces dispositions sont bien respectés au
moins on prend des mesures mais pour
vérifier qu'elles soient bien respectées
on anticipe déjà un contrôle à effectuer
ça montre bien que ce traité est loin
d'être une simple déclaration
d'intention il y à de vraies
conséquences prévues et concernant les
conséquences on prévoit aussi un autre
point absolument capital
qu'est-ce qu'il se passe si jamais un
conflit à paris quand on rédige un
traité international
il est important d'anticiper cette
question qui tranchera en cas de litige
ce point est évidemment une énorme
luttes de pouvoir puisque chaque partie
au traité va essayer de faire en sorte
que les arbitres lui soit favorable
le traité se cantonne à expliquer qu'en
premier lieu les parties doivent tenter
de gérer leurs différends par des moyens
pacifiques
bon jusque là rien de très surprenant si
ça échoue et qu'on n'arrive pas à
trouver une solution ce serait la cour
internationale de justice qui tranchera
sauf que là on retombe sur un problème
qui n'est pas du tout propre à
l'antarctique
la cour internationale de justice n'a
que des moyens très limités puisqu'il
est difficile d'influencer un état tout
entier ce qui fait qu'il ya eu déjà
énormément de blocage dans le passé
je n'ai pas vraiment le temps de
développer ce point précis mais je vous
ai mis des sous sans description si
jamais vous voulez approfondir le sujet
retenez simplement qu'il est difficile
d'exercer une contrainte au niveau
international sur un état parce que
l'état reste souvent dans une certaine
mesure donc pour lan party que ça
pourrait être la même issue en résumé il
n'y a plus qu'à croiser les doigts pour
qu'il n'y ait pas de souci bref en avant
sur le sujet puisqu'on prend des mesures
au niveau international basé sur la
coopération entre les états et l'idée
que l'antarctique doit rester une zone
neutre et pacifique mais on n'a pas
vraiment régler tous les problèmes
on a évité que les revendications
territoriales se multiplient et s'enlise
pas quelque chose de conflictuelle mais
on reste en stand by on a gelé un statu
quo ah oui je lai ok c'est un jeu de
mots en fête genre jeu l'effroi
antarctique
ferme ta gueule
l'avantagé c'est que l'antarctique aura
permis d' apaiser certaines tensions
entre les états unis et l'urss
à cette même période les deux pays
entreront en pourparlers concernant la
limitation des essais nucléaires
initiative couronnée de succès en 1963
peut-être que cette situation
d'apaisement concernant l'antarctique à
oeuvrer en ce sens comme il était
convenu dans le traité les parties
signataires se sont par la suite réunit
régulièrement
après la signature du traité sur
l'antarctique de 1959 on signera en 1981
la convention sur la conservation de la
faune et de la flore marines de
l'antarctique qui entrera en vigueur en
1982 il est ensuite apparu qu'il fallait
préciser certaines positions tout la
signature du protocole de madrid en 1991
le protocole de madrid se fait dans le
même esprit que le traité de 1959
sauf qu'il est beaucoup plus axée sur la
préservation de cet espace pour des
raisons environnementales
les parties signataires vont même
convenir que l'antarctique soit désigné
comme réserve naturelle consacrée à la
paix et à la science
ce qui est une très jolie formule le
protocole va aussi créer un comité pour
la protection de l'environnement pour
tenter de limiter l'impact de l'être
humain sur cette faune et cette flore si
fragile et précieux on cherche à
rappeler au niveau international cette
nécessité absolue de préservation en
renforçant les moyens de contrôle
le problème c'est que faire respecter
les traités internationaux bas c'est un
petit peu complexe une loi nationale
repose sur un texte notre juge contrôler
sa bonne application et si c'est pas
respectés par endroits un personal ben
il ya moins de contrainte parce que si
on veut pousser les états à s'engager si
on leur tape trop sur les doigts ils
viendront plus trump par exemple s'est
retiré de plein de traités
internationaux et c'est compliqué à
gérer pour tout miser sur la bonne
volonté des états et vous conviendrez
que c'est pas évident les états les
mêmes qu'en 1959 continue de revendiquer
leur part ce qui n'est pas reconnu à
l'international mais n'est pas une
source de conflits non plus dans les
années 70 et 80 le chili et l'argentine
on organisait des accouchements sur
leurs bases respectives pour asseoir
leurs revendications territoriales genre
ils ont fait dépêcher des femmes
enceintes de sept ou huit mois pour
qu'elle accouche sur leurs bases en
antarctique mais il était mais ultra des
terres en fête pour ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement la france
nous revendiquons les terres australes
et antarctiques françaises abrégée par
l'acronyme taaf
ces terres sont considérées comme un
territoire d'outre-mer selon une loi
datant de 1955 soit avant la signature
du premier traité il lui est même fait
mention dans notre fameuse constitution
mais en gros c'est pas vraiment reconnue
au niveau international
on a aussi une autre difficulté de
préservation qui se fait sentir et elle
est bien plus récentes
c'est celle du tourisme on estime qu'en
1990 il y avait 3000 touristes à l'année
en antarctique et ils sont un peu plus
de 37000 en 2015
mais ce tourisme est assez particulier
il est intéressant de noter que
l'association internationale des
voyagistes
d'arctic va concentrer le flux de plus
de 80 % des touristes sur ce continent
elle établit un code de conduite le but
n'est pas de faire du tourisme classique
mais plus pédagogique orienté par une
coopération avec les scientifiques
il est toutefois important de maintenir
des règles strictes pour que le tourisme
en antarctique ne perturbe ni la faune
ni la flore locale ni le travail de
recherche effectué sur place
il ya encore un enjeu de taille à
relever en 2048 il faudra réviser les
accords concernant l'antarctique pour ça
il faudra que tous les pays s'entendent
et ils sont 28 donc ça va pas être
gagnée on leur souhaite une bonne bon
courage
la question revient sans cesse
concernant l'extraction des ressources
certains pays comme la russie cherche à
obtenir des autorisations pour extraire
le charbon et le pétrole qui sont
présents donc vous vous en doutez ces
extractions elle pourrait mettre mal
l'equilibre de cet écosystème si
précieux 2048 ça paraît loin et pas tant
que ça en même temps pour l'instant la
position de la france serait de faire
placer l'antarctique au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco
ce qui pour les experts sur le sujet
serait probablement l'issue la plus
préférable
concernant l'absolue nécessité de
continuer à préserver cet endroit unique
au monde qu'est l'inde arctique en
refusant qu'on extrait les ressources
naturelles par exemple je voudrais finir
en citant cet article du monde qui date
2011 mais qui est plus que jamais
d'actualité
cette menace environnementale est
occulté aujourd'hui par les crises de
dette souveraine long terme disparaît
devant l'urgence ce n'est pas le moindre
des paradoxes
car le système financier nous rappelle
que nous finissons toujours par payer
nos dettes comme le système climatique
nous fera payer plus tard la dette que
nous contractons aujourd'hui en
chargeant l'atmosphère de carbone la
mise en garde s'impose donc le sous sol
de l'antarctique et peut être diablement
tentant mais il a tous les traits d'une
boîte de pandore
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu n'hésitez
pas à liker à la partager
à vous abonner à activer la cloche et
puis on se retrouvera sur discorde pour
en discuter tous ensemble
donc n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre et
sur ce je vous dis à bientôt
bon du coup faut qu'on trouve une autre
solution pour ma cousine et je vous
préviens tout de suite elle mérite le
respect qu'on lui doit trouver un
endroit bien pour elle jamais on a mangé
la batelière et alors ce qu'on l'import
des séquelles la place dans le congèle
on n'a qu'à la mettre là dedans en
attendant
[Musique]
je suis actuellement en live sur twitter
pourquoi débriefer l'épisode avec vous
sur l'antarctique
donc n'hésitez pas à venir je vous
attends avec ceux ci
c'est mon petit bout d'antarctique amant